Скільки отримує вчитель-пенсіонер, який народився
ще у Третьому Рейху?
Пенсія - час німецькій бабусі сідати на мотоцикл!
Чому дипломатам на пенсії подобається
блошиний ринок?
Друзі, всім привіт! Я продовжую реагувати на ваші коментарі,
і ця серія присвячена пенсійній системі Німеччини і пенсіонерам.
З 80 мільйонів населення ФРН - 25 мільйонів - пенсіонери.
Ось так виглядає будинок для літніх людей Німецького Червоного Хреста -
з нього відкривається чудовий вид на Рейн і гори.
А у цьому маєтку розташований приватний будинок для літніх людей.
Місяць перебування у ньому коштує від трьох тисяч євро.
Однак у цій серії я пропоную познайомитися бл ижче з пенсіонерами,
які ведуть самостійне, активне життя.
Їду за 30 кілометрів від Бонна у місто Ойскірхен.
Саме випав сніг - таке останніми роками буває у Рейнському регіоні доволі рідко.
В Ойскірхені мене зустрічає пан Рюдіґер Вестфаль.
Він вчитель мистецтва на пенсії.
Пану Вестфалю 74 роки. Він досі щосереди 6 годин проводить заняття у гімназії.
У Німеччині такий вид заробітку називають міні-джоб -
це прибуток, який не перевищує 450 євро на місяць.
Пан Вестфаль каже, що робить це заради того, щоб передати знання, і не ставить оцінок.
Далі господар запрошує до своєї мистецької галереї.
Ласкаво просимо до об'єднання підтримки сучасного мистецтва округу Ойскірхен.
Від різноманіття кольорів розбігаються очі. Ця частина галереї - житлова.
Тут є міні-кухня, пральна машина, ліжко, запас харчів.
А це я. Можна легко розпізнати по животу.
А це гостьова книга, де митці з різних куточків світу, які тут зупиняються,
залишають автографи і побажання.
Пан Вестфаль розлучений і не має дітей.
Він єдиний, хто погодився відкрито розповісти нам про розмір своєї пенсії.
Сума до вирахування податків - 3677 євро,
після податків - дві тисячі дев'ятсот шістдесят євро, десять центів.
Ось така правда.
А це свідоцтво про народження пана Вестфаля - 10 травня 1944 року.
Видане ще у Третьому Рейху.
Народжені до 1947 року можуть виходити на пенсію у ФРН у 65 років. Рюдіґер так і зробив.
Причина його високої пенсії в тому, що німецькі вчителі,
які працюють у державних навчальних закладах, отримують статус держслужбовця.
Серед усіх пенсійних виплат у ФРН високі пенсії службовців - це лише близько 10 відсотків.
Середній розмір пенсії у німецьких чоловіків - близько 1200 євро, у жінок - понад 700 євро.
У роки німецького економічного дива жінки працювали майже нарІвні з чоловіками.
А коли у 60-х роках минулого століття прийшов достаток,
жінкам дедалі частіше стали відводити роль матерів та домогосподарок -
чоловіки заробляли достатньо, щоб утримувати сім'ю.
Власне, через те, що жінки працювали менше, ніж чоловіки, у них нині відповідно значно менші пенсії.
Рюдіґер Вестфаль попри пенсійний вік веде надзвичайно активне життя.
Виставки в його галереї постійно змінюються.
У найближчі три місяці в цій галереї виставлятимуться роботи
місцевого 84-річного художника.
Друзі, ви лише подивіться на розмір цього скла.
Його довжина – сім метрів, висота – два з половиною метри.
Пан Вестфаль запрошує художників творити прямо у своїй галереї.
Ось тут є мольберт.
Тож, люди, які проходять на вулиці можуть через це величезне вікно, бачити як художник малює.
За словами пана Вестфаля, усе своє професійне життя він викладав у гімназії
не лише історію мистецтва та основи композиції,
а й намагався донести учням цінність відчуття свободи.
Він зберігає документи своєї родини, які нагадують йому про ті часи,
коли ні у мистецтві, ні у суспільстві про свободу й не йшлося.
Це так званий "аненпас". Документ, який мав підтверджувати арійське походження.
У Третьому Рейху кожна родина була зобов'язана мати документальне підтвердження того,
що ти вісім поколінь мав арійців у своїй родословній.
Я залишаю засніжений Ойскірхен і повертаюся до Бонна,
де домовився про зустріч з пенсіонеркою пані Фассбендер.
Вона мешкає у звичайному багатоквартирному будинку. Їй 83 роки.
Щоранку роблю зарядку. Після сніданку 20 хвилин.
Чоловік Анни-Марії Фассбендер помер 10 років тому.
Вони прожили разом 54 роки. Чоловік працював слюсарем.
Пані Фассбендер лише 6 років пропрацювала медсестрою,
а потім займалася вихованням двох дітей і все життя була домогосподаркою.
Право на отримання пенсії у Німеччині надається,
якщо людина офіційно пропрацювала мінімум 5 років, тобто 60 місяців сплачувала страхові внески.
Розмір внеску наразі 18,6 відсотків від зарплати.
Половину платить працівник, половину - роботодавець.
Як вдова пані Фассбендер тепер отримує і пенсію свого чоловіка.
У віці 80 років вона пройшла 120 кілометрів паломницького шляху Святого Якова в Іспанії.
Співає в хорі і регулярно ходить до басейну.
Пенсіонери у Німеччині дуже активні.
Щодо мене - я хочу перебувати у гарній фізичній формі навіть у старості.
Я не хочу, щоб за мною доводилося доглядати іншим. Я не хочу лише сидіти в кріслі і їсти.
Я багато рухаюся, щоб я ще довго отримувала задоволення від життя,
щоб не бути тягарем для дітей, щоб залишатися здоровою та активною.
А ось так виглядає двір багатоквартирного будинку.
Німці - великі поціновувачі затишку і комфорту.
Тож, пані Фассбендер має під боком чудове місце для щоденних прогулянок.
А тепер пропоную переміститися у сільську місцевість неподалік містечка Санкт-Августин.
Тут саме проходить ярмарок ремесел.
Ковальство, ткацтво, плетіння.
Майстер-клас з плетіння проводить 82-річний Едвін Шретер.
Головна ідея цього курсу - привернути увагу до того,
що з простих матеріалів можна самому щось сплести.
Пан Шретер нещодавно видав навіть цІлу книгу про плетіння, над якою працював кілька років.
Він прагне передати нащадкам свою майстерність
і ділиться у книзі всіма хитрощами і секретами ремесла.
А це місцева газета написала про плетений тин, який зробив пан Шретер.
Майстра також час від часу запрошують робити унікальний садовий дизайн.
Едвін Шретер - пізній переселенець.
Він переїхав до Німеччини з Росії у віці 57 років.
Громадянство отримав одразу, бо є етнічним німцем.
У ФРН йому зарахували половину робочого стажу в СРСР.
Пан Шретер відмовився називати розмір своєї пенсії.
Але виходячи із середньої пенсії пізніх переселенців,
можна припустити, що вона становить приблизно 600 євро.
Коли самотні пенсіонери отримують невелику пенсію,
держава допомагає ще різними соціальними виплатами на оренду житла
або обслуговування у будинку для літніх людей.
Едвін народився у 1937 році, у селі Радичі Житомирської області.
Був сьомою дитиною у німецькій родині.
Під час німецької окупації радянської України всі етнічні німці
отримали громадянство Третього Рейху.
Пану Шретеру довелося тричі йти у перший клас. У 1943-му в Україні у німецьку школу.
Після переїзду до Рейху у 44-му пішов у школу під Лейпцигом.
Потім у 45-му по закінченні війни радянська влада депортувала сім'ю за Урал.
Там пішов у російськомовну школу.
Коли виріс, працював в СРСР і майстром трудового навчання, і перекладачем,
і гідом у компанії "Інтурист".
Після розпаду СРСР вирішив емігрувати до Німеччини.
А пам'ятаєте, у третій серії циклу про переробку сміття на цьому ж місці,
на блошиному ринку міста Бонн, я продавав свій старий велосипед?
І його таки вдалося продати завдяки порадам пенсіонерки фрау Кімме.
Тоді ми з нею поговорили і про її життя на пенсії.
Блошиний ринок міста Бонн, німецькою "фломаркт" - це не лише місце,
де вживані речі отримують нове життя.
Раз на місяць боннський парк Райнауе перетворюється на центр соціалізації,
де тисячі людей легко заводять розмови з незнайомцями -
і не лише задля того, щоб збити ціну.
Моя сусідка за торговим місцем, пані Доріс Кімме зізналася, що одяг вона продає не заради прибутку -
просто їй подобається атмосфера "фломаркту".
Це ще один спосіб проведення часу, який полюбляють активні німецькі пенсіонери.
Я роблю це вже вчетверте, у мене доволі добре виходить,
і це приносить задоволення, а також дає можливість знайомитися з людьми.
Зараз я пенсіонерка, раніше працювала у міністерстві закордонних справ,
чиновницею у німецьких посольствах.
Через це кожні чотири роки я переїжджала до іншої країни.
Я була в Індії, в Китаї - у Шанхаї, в Джакарті, в Перу, всюди потрохи.
Дипломатичний досвід дається взнаки: речі у пані Кімме розліталися як гарячі пиріжки.
Вона має статус службовця, тож отримує високу пенсію, як і вчитель гімназії Рюдіґер Вестфаль.
Зверніть увагу на вбрання цього пана.
От такі стильні пенсіонери приходять на "фломаркт".
Також тут, на "фломаркті", мені вдалося познайомитися ще з однією пенсіонеркою.
пані Евелін Сет.
Я вже приблизно років тридцять підторговую на "фломаркті".
Продаю переважно прикраси і одяг.
Пані Сет захоплюється подорожами на мотоциклі за кордоном.
Це її мотопробіг Непалом у 2015 році.
Виручені від пробігу благодійні кошти учасники акції спрямували
на допомогу постраждалим від землетрусу.
Евелін Сет з радістю показала свій BMW.
Пані Сет вийшла на пенсію на кілька років раніше встановленого терміну через стан здоров'я.
Пенсійний вік для чоловіків та жінок у Німеччині настає з 67 років.
Евелін Сет сказала, що пенсії їй вистачає лише, щоб платити за оренду житла і комунальні послуги.
Жінка працювала на ринку нерухомості, тож, окрім пенсії, має ще власні заощадження.
Друзі, пишіть, що ще вам цікаво знати про Німеччину,
і я обов'язково про це розповім у наступних серіях.